hey what's going on everybody it is june
20th 2022 i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report we are live streaming on
rumble blaze tv and youtube and i'm in a
good mood i had a great weekend i hope
you did too i hope you celebrated your
father or if you
uh are a father to be or were a father
or gonna be a father or any version of a
father or something or you have a father
or whatever i hope uh there was some
goodness over your weekend hope you ate
some hot dogs and all that good
stuff i'm feeling refreshed and ready to
roll so today's show
is going to be i i asked the guys right
before what are we going to do uh what
level of show are we going to do today
michael said in 8 6 out of 10
phoenix said what do you say an 8-8 you
said an 8-8 conor went with the six four
you kind of went with the six four not
feeling that i'm gonna do much today
i'm feeling a nine two but i'll let you
guys be the judge in about a half hour
what we're gonna be talking about today
is that the woke thing really is
crumbling it really really is crumbling
and we don't want to get too
overconfident but we should acknowledge
it and we should encourage its crumble
and not only is it crumbling but that is
happening in conjunction with this biden
thing falling apart and joe biden
himself fallen off a bike as you guys
all saw uh this weekend and then of
course we'll talk a little bit about
fauci he's back for just a second and
rand paul smacked him down pretty good
oh and he has coveted despite his 87
shots uh quick reminder guys my first
ever stand up special don't say dave is
available right now for 9.99
that's all we're charging for at 9.99
you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
for a one-time purchase of 9.99 or you
can subscribe annually and you get it
absolutely free okay let's just dive
right in today so the woke thing that is
crumbling uh is becoming very obvious to
everyone except a certain set mostly of
hollywood
related people who think if they still
apologize for things that they've done
whether they really feel guilty about it
or not that they will be given some sort
of leash by the woken it just doesn't
work so you guys know rain wilson
actor rain wilson he tweeted this out
over the weekend and i thought this was
an interesting way to start the show
today rayne wilson yesterday i tweeted a
mean crack about breastfeeding versus
chest feeding after speaking with some
trans friends and educating myself a bit
more i want to apologize for the tweet
it was adding to misinformation and
meanness i'm sorry now
i don't even know what the original
tweet was it is irrelevant what the
original tweet was the reason that i
thought this was sort of important to
start today's show with is that he got
ratioed into oblivion with this thing
meaning that no one thinks that whatever
his original tweet was was intentionally
offensive chest feeding breastfeeding
only women can breastfeed all of these
things that we all know right like
nobody was offended by it but then he
talked to his trans friends which is
just you know that's not true
and then they do all these things but
the pushback on this like the pushback
on these fake apologies i think is
important it's just not necessary
anymore placating to these hysterical
losers and these activists and keyboard
warriors and and bots it is not working
anymore so he got ratio that's what we
call it if you're in the online world
when you tweet something that is really
stupid or deeply untrue and then the
internet's like no fool you don't have
to apologize for that or this isn't
going to get you the
they're not going to grant you the the
niceties that you're going for with this
but there was another one you guys know
author james patterson he is one of the
biggest non-fiction thriller writers
probably in the last 50 years in america
he had one look at this his apology i
apologize for saying white male writers
have trouble finding work is a form of
racism i absolutely do not believe that
racism is practiced against white
writers please know that i strongly
support a diversity of voices being
heard in literature in hollywood
everywhere so of course this is not true
he said it because he believed it
then this activist mob goes after him
and then he and then he says i
absolutely don't believe the thing that
i just said and of course there's
discrimination against white people
across industries once you say we are
going to elevate a certain group of
people meaning we're going to elevate
black people or gay people or trans
people or whatever it might be you have
to discriminate against another set of
people right harvard is the best example
of this harvard said we want more black
students so once you say we want more
black students you can't just endlessly
allow people to enter the school you
don't just open up the roles and say
okay we want a thousand more black
students let's let a thousand more
students in you have to say okay we now
have to
be prejudiced actually be prejudice and
discriminate against a certain set of
people so in harvard's mind they said
okay who can we be prejudiced against
will be prejudiced against those asian
kids so they made it harder for asian
kids to get in and easier for black kids
to get in this is what equity does it
just moves the prejudice so these fake
apologies
that reign wilson dwight schrute from
the office is somehow transphobic and
that he has to issue this idiotic
apology he talked to his trans friends
and realized the chess feeding whatever
okay and that uh james patterson uh that
he said the obvious truth which is i can
tell you this anyone knows this in
hollywood
with whatever remaining ties i still
have to to old hollywood through agents
or whatever it's of course they would
much rather a black trans disabled uh
talk show host than a straight white guy
everyone knows that why is trevor noah
the still the host of the daily show
it's because he's black it's not because
anyone's watching the show or thinks
he's good nobody thinks he's funny
nobody thinks he's interesting the show
went from being hugely culturally
relevant to nothing but they're afraid
to fire him because they don't want to
be called racist that's how the game is
played that's just the truth sorry media
matters i know you're going to come
after me for that one it's just the
truth but the point of all this why am i
starting the show with the tweet from
rayne wilson you know an ad a relevant
actor and james patterson a a an author
it's not that they are so important it's
that the pushback against the fake
apologies the pushback against cancel
culture is working and that is good and
it's also leaking now into our politics
this is the key part uh i mentioned last
week there was this incredible win in
texas uh by this uh maya flores this
really fantastic win that she got in and
uh elon musk supported her and now we
know
that latinos are leaving the democrat
party in droves they are leaving leave
and leaving and even cnn is talking
about it there are differences in what's
going on with the latino vote if you
look at texas florida and arizona these
are three districts that are a little
bit let's call them emblematic of what
we're talking about florida 27 this is
the miami-dade area it went from being
clinton by 19 in 2016 to biden by just
three in 2020. texas 15 that is on the
mexico border clinton 16 to biden plus
two arizona this is the tucson area so
arizona is a place that some democrats
say
think that helped biden win that state
it went from clinton 29 to biden 27 so
not a huge shift but still
in texas and in florida there are big
erosions happening big erosion's
happening
you see how she didn't want to say the
last part she kind of paused she was
kind of choking on her words
it's happening but still it's happening
everyone gets why this is happening
there's many reasons why it's happening
first off
generally speaking latino communities
whether they are mexican or honduran or
wherever they might be from they lean in
their in their cultural norms they lean
a little more conservative the democrats
have done a great job they've
particularly done this with the black
community you know my feelings on the
word community that they've confused
people into thinking that big government
means good things that if we give you
things that is good but the ethics the
cultural values of these communities
tend to be a little more conservative
then you take what's going on in texas
with these open borders and people
that are just pouring through our
borders well if you were a new immigrant
to america a legal immigrant and you did
it fairly right or it was your father or
mother or grandparents that did it
fairly and you lived in one of these
border communities and you're working
hard and doing the american dream doing
what you probably are doing right now or
what your parents or grandparents your
great-grandparents did before you and
you're working hard to get more so that
your kids will have more and all of that
stuff and then you see in your border
town somewhere in texas you see all
these people just pouring in and the
government's going to give them money
and the government's going to give them
phones and other benefits and all of
those things you might be annoyed and
then you might be able to connect that
to the policies of the biden
administration and then you might even
be able to remember back to that orange
man who was talking about building a
wall and it wasn't a racist wall it was
a wall that just said hey we've got a
border and a border if you want to
actualize it it would be a physical
thing known as a wall and we can all
talk about whether a wall makes the most
sense or electronic surveillance or some
part of a wall and some part of
electronic surveillance or boats or
alligators or whatever it might be but
the point is when you take the
immigration stuff that is huge you take
some of the cultural norms boys or girls
and all of that stuff that doesn't
really fly with these people and then
you take the ridiculous
language of the woke the tanks
l-a-t-i-n-x the latinx a word that no
latino person has ever said it is wildly
offensive most of the words in spanish
are gendered right that's how it works
that's how it works and they have
completely pushed all this nonsense on
these people it's all coming from elite
white liberals that's how it comes from
the woke and they're pushing it on these
people it's even related to something
going on here as i've been telling you
guys we're doing construction in my
house but a lot of the workers
that i've had in my house happen to be
from honduras and i talk to them my
spanish is pretty decent we go back and
forth like the idea that they would love
that this the the main guy running the
show here uh that he would want his
daughter to be a boy or boy to be a
daughter or any of these like it's just
so ridiculous they're here to work hard
and build a better life for themselves
much like everybody else that's sane
but on the televised mental institution
of nbc
they are also acknowledging that there's
a big problem uh for the democrats when
it comes to minorities because the
democrats have basically owned
minorities and what happens when
minorities start figuring out what's
what what do you have to do
you've got to scare the hell out of them
you know what african-americans
particularly african-american men who
are showing the lowest motivation to
turn out in this midterm you think
things are are tough for you right now
where do you think you're going to
stand in a country like in america where
there's where there's no democracy where
they have absolutely no interest or
at all and and respecting you respecting
your respecting your rights we've got to
get
let these people understand that they've
got skin in this game and they've got
and they got we got to scare the hell
out of them because quite frankly nicole
they should be afraid that we're going
to lose our democracy
it's a fantasy land it's genuinely a
fantasy land there are people that watch
msnbc and it's it's not that many people
anymore right it's not that many people
anymore but there's a set of people that
are influential in the political world
that watch that that respond to that and
you're watching that thinking that what
are you saying the republicans are
coming for your rights the republicans
are coming for black people and all of
those things as you guys know we've
talked about it a million times
black and latino unemployment was at an
all-time low
uh when donald trump was president when
the congressional black caucus sat there
when he said it remember he said it at
the state of the union black and latino
unemployment at all time man we don't
like you orange man we hate you more
than we like black and latino people
uh but this is all leaking into
everything right now because as we watch
the woke thing crumble and as we watch
uh latino black gay
minority of choice people fleeing the
democrat party this is directly
connected to the guy who fell off the
bike this weekend and his uh disapproval
numbers are going way up let's just
watch him falling off the bike again
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so first off i'll do the not funny
like there's a million jokes we can
throw in there now let's just do the
joke part first and that'll be all right
let's just show the trump version one
more time
okay all right so we can do all the
funny versions of this but i really want
you to think about how close we got to
today being very different than
yesterday uh that's a roughly eight how
old is he 79 78 something i think he's
79 right that's a 79 year old man
falling off a bike when a 79 year old
man falls off a bike usually that's the
last time they get on a bike uh if
they're lucky because you could very
easily break a hip break something else
this is a guy who's had a series i think
he's had a couple of brain aneurysms
like we all know about the general state
of his mental health and all that you
know physically in terms of his body he
actually for a 79 year old looks like
he's in decent enough shape uh but the
point is that if he falls one inch one
way or one inch the other way uh that's
the broken hit right and we know what
happens when old people break their hip
i'm not being glib or funny about it or
whatever i would like not like to break
my hip as a matter of fact i'm doing two
times a week now i'm going to physical
therapy because i got something going on
with my shoulders so this is not to mock
anyone's physical abilities but the
point is
that the guy is 79 years old and had he
fallen slightly differently
do you know what would be happening
right now
do you know
do you want to sit with it for just a
minute it's i'm freaking people out
right now you guys are freaking out i
can tell
basically
kamala harris would be in charge
okay
if that doesn't freak you out if that
isn't the scariest freaking thing you've
ever heard then i don't know what is
okay uh so we need to talk about these
things right
he is not well and we are that close we
are we were one you know there was a
little pebble that he would have fallen
a little bit differently one way or
another broken hip he's in the hospital
and there we go uh but
uh the machine the machine still likes
him now remember the machine when donald
trump uh drank water with two hands
remember they said he couldn't hold a
glass of water donald trump one day in
the rain he walked down a ramp slowly
and they said he was going to fall and
he can't balance the series of reasons
that we impeached him and they said
things were wrong with him and all of
those things but here was the headline
in the atlantic yesterday after biden
fell
the heroism of biden's bike fall the
president gracefully illustrated an
important lesson for all americans when
we fall we must get back up
we had a whole bunch of headlines that
uh were the complete reverse when trump
walked down the ramp slowly and i was
like ah we don't have to show them
because everyone gets it that these same
organizations that they run cover when
it's democrats they run complete offense
when
it's republicans but the point is they
can't hide this much longer they can't
hide his ineptitude they can't hide the
bad ratings they can't hide the fact
that he can't read the teleprompter and
that when he does go off teleprompter
that it's a muddled mess they can't hide
it much longer uh here on nbc is
politico's betsy woodruff swann talking
about this problem that they have
related to hiding this guy
the staff seems overly protective
yeah there's no question and that's part
of the reason he's out front so little
he's done such a tiny number of recent
interviews and now of course in this ap
interview the message that he's sending
that people are highlighting is he's
recognizing that there's a lot of pain
and suffering in this country giving
people a little jimmy carter flashback
you know a word he never actually said
but malaise uh his infamous malaise
speech and that's something that senior
white house staff are acutely aware of
once the mainstream media starts
relating this thing to jimmy carter and
the malaise then it's like oh we would
rather have anybody and jimmy carter
very famously gave a speech around 1980
or so about this malaise this depression
that everyone knew they were in and gas
prices were sky high and everything else
and then you know who came in this
ronald reagan guy and we had a pretty
damn good eight years in america but
it's not just the immediate problems
that they have right like the gas stuff
and the inflation stuff which is really
crazy and we're not even going to get
that far into it and it's not just biden
falling off his bike and whatever's
going on with him cognitively and
everything else it's that some of the
other stuff that they've done to us for
the last two years is really coming to
the light and their hypocrisy and
nonsense is really being exposed in real
time so i don't know if you saw this one
but on friday anthony fauci remember him
we haven't talked about him in a while
he announced that he's got the coven
cnn breaking news dr anthony fauci has
tested positive for covet 19 and has
mild symptoms he is fully vaccinated and
received two booster shots
[Laughter]
fully vaccinated i thought if you get
vaccinated for something you don't get
the thing
that's the way it used to be and then
they kind of changed the definition in
the middle and they said no no no this
vaccine doesn't work that way this
vaccine if you get vaccinated means you
won't get
as strong a version of the thing that
you're going to get vaccine has never
been known to do that before by the way
there is literally no and i would
welcome anyone to fact check me on this
i had a long discussion with this with
jordan peterson about two weeks ago
there is no evidence there are no
clinical trials to prove that if you get
vaccinated you will have lesser version
of cova it just simply does not exist
but everyone says it and everyone
repeats it repeats it repeats it and
repeats it you may remember anthony
fauci when it came to vaccines
when people are vaccinated they can feel
safe that they are not going to get
infected hopefully
the more people they get vaccinated and
boosted and the more people that realize
the importance
of when you have a high level of viral
dynamics
that when you're in an indoor setting
you should wear a mask
even though
the whole world including the united
states and the uk
are just worn out and tired
by this outbreak it isn't over yet
people need to realize
it is never going to go back to zero
that's not the nature of this virus
so just to be clear anthony fauci lied
or spread misinformation when he told
you that if you got the vaccine you
wouldn't get it and then we added that
second clip in just to show that no
matter what they want you in masks
forever they want to scare a certain
amount of people but of course it's not
just anthony mauchi that was lying about
the vaccines uh remember the elderly man
pretending to be president who just fell
off his bike here he was back in june
okay you're not gonna you're not gonna
get covet if you have these vaccinations
you're not gonna get covet if you have
these vaccinations and yet anthony fauci
of the cdc
of the nih wherever the hell he works at
this point does he even work in the ni
he works at the nih right not the cdc no
one even matters it doesn't even matter
he is an old buffoon who should be
rotting in a prison cell
and if rand paul has his way i'm pretty
sure that's what's going to happen to
anthony fauci because
here he was friday on the very day that
they announced that fauci had coveted
here's rand paul just grilling the hell
out of him on vaccine misinformation
dr fauci the government recommends uh
everybody take a booster over age five
are you aware of any studies that show
reduction in hospitalization or death
for children who take a booster
right now there's not enough data that
has been accumulated senator paul
to indicate that that's the case there
are no studies on children showing a
reduction in hospitalization or death
with taking a booster if i give you 10
or if i give a patient 10 mrna vaccines
and they make protein each time or they
make antibody each time is that proof
that we should give 10 boosters dr fauci
no i think that is somewhat of an absurd
exaggeration
so that is the proof that you use your
committees use that that's the only
proof you have to tell children to take
a booster is that they make antibodies
so it's not an absurdity you're already
at like five boosters for people you've
had you know two or three boosters it's
like where is the proof
now i think there is probably some
indication for older folks that have
some risk factors for younger folks
there's not
rand paul is really fantastic you know
we can bash on politic politicians all
the time and you know there's a short
list of politicians i like but he really
is great and he's got the chops when
he's in those conversations right he
actually is a doctor what's incredible
about that now first off it came out
that fauci had coveted a little bit
after that but you can hear it in fauci
that he's obviously not feeling well but
we really need to think about this the
cdc is now recommending boosters
basically for five-year-olds there is no
evidence that it works and fouchy's
admitting it and they're still pushing
it do you realize how insane that is two
and a half years after two weeks to
flatten the curve how completely insane
it is and rand paul continued to to bash
him on these lies and this
misinformation when it comes to vaccine
kids and if you look at the data from
israel
the boost both the third shot boost and
the fourth shot boost was associated
with a clear-cut clinical effect mostly
in elderly people but also as they
gathered more data
even in people in the 40s and the 50s so
there is clinical data but not in
children
well well see here's the thing is you're
not willing to be honest with the
american people so for example 75
percent of kids have had the disease
why is the cdc not including this in the
data you can ask the question you can do
laboratory tests to find out who's had
it and who hasn't had the disease
what is the incidence of hospitalization
and death for children who have been
infected with kovid
subsequently going to the hospital or
dying what what is the possibility if
your kid has had covid which is 75 of
the country's head covered what is the
chance that my child's going to the
hospital or dying
if you look at the number of deaths in
pediatrics senator
you can see that there are more deaths
of people who have had it
but people have had the disease
senator we also know from other studies
that the optimal degree of protection
when you get infection is to get
vaccinated after infection but you can't
answer the question i ask the question i
ask is how many kids are dying and how
many kids are going to the hospital who
have already had covid the answer may be
zero but you're not even giving us the
data because you have so much wanted to
protect everybody from all the data
because we're not smart enough to look
at the data when you release data
earlier when the cdc released the data
they left out the category of 18 to 49
on whether or not there was a health
benefit for for adults 18 to 49 why was
it left out
when critics finally complained it was
finally included because there was no
health benefit from taking a booster
between the 18 to 49 and the cdc study
you know it's interesting the government
has all sorts of hearings all the time
and it's usually just like pure nonsense
and theatrics and nothing comes of any
of it but i thought this was important
to show you because rand paul is
prosecuting him right there right he's
prosecuting him and eventually he'll be
persecuting him because
what he is saying what fauci is saying
is oh there is a study in another
country in this case in israel that
third and fourth booster shots for
adults does something and it gives you
this sort of amorphous and it kind of
does something for 40 and 50 year olds
and and rand says well wait a minute so
this has nothing to do with kids you
have no numbers related to kids and
because of this study in another country
from 40 to on 40 to 50 year olds you now
want to inject our kids even further and
fauci's got nothing he's got nothing he
is a criminal and a fraud that's what
anthony fauci is and if you don't think
this stuff is dangerous still why is
this stuff still dangerous okay so let's
say kovid's over or they're gonna bring
it back before the election or you've
just made whatever your personal
decision is related to covid crazy dave
rubin unvaccinated over here out and
about on a daily basis interacting with
human beings real nutbag here's a little
info from the new york times about
what's going on right now why did
approving covid19 vaccines for the
youngest children take so long a change
in how vaccines were evaluated would
have allowed us to possibly make a
different decision about allowing a
vaccine to move forward earlier said a
scientist a scientist now what is he
referring to well white house chief of
staff ron klein chimed in with this and
now you'll get it
the u.s is about to become the first
country on earth to give mrna vaccines
to its youngest children the first
i have a feeling that ronald klein klein
whatever his name is will end up in jail
or something why would you be injecting
your children with this thing that as
rand paul just pointed out no studies
have been done on
no evidence to suggest it will stop
these kids getting coveted there's no
studies on the efficacy of it there's no
evidence that children need it or aren't
recovering from kovid we have no idea
really what injecting an mrna of
relatively new technology into young
children
is going to do there are studies that
show it increases myocarditis in young
boys which rand paul made a point to say
to anthony fauci why would you do this i
have to tell you i saw this over the
weekend and as you guys know you know
we're about to have two kids and the
idea that the government would be
pushing these things even now there is
no way i want to be very clear about
this anthony falci there is no way over
my dead body that i am injecting my kids
with your experimental medication you
know or vaccine whatever you want to
call it you know every commercial on
television is about something you have
depression for this or you have [ __ ]
bladder or hysterical pregnancy arrest
restless leg syndrome and what are all
the commercials all the commercials are
take this pill and it's going to maybe
solve that but not for everybody and
then what does what does the commercial
do in the last 75 of the commercial oh
you're gonna have diarrhea and vomiting
and potential suicide and crazy thoughts
and
it's going to destroy your liver and
everything else if you take too much
advil that is bad for you every single
medication that is in your bathroom
right now right has some sort of side
effects but for this thing they want to
push it on everybody including your
children i mean they're literally going
after children they're telling your
children that boys or girls and girls
are boys they want to inject them with
[ __ ] and we're all just sitting here and
taking it but not all of us because not
you're not and i'm not and that's pretty
good that is pretty pretty good but
where does this all lead now to the
shift of the show where we talk about
what the what the good part of this is
the silver lining on this thing the
democrats are crumbling and the
republicans are actually doing some some
good work and it's and it's uh it's
first and fore take a look at this from
rnc research
red states
right now 21 of the top 26 states with
the lowest unemployment rates are led by
republican governors now this should not
shock anyone at all because generally
speaking in red states you have lower
taxes when you have lower taxes you have
more
a chance for businesses to flourish
because people have a little bit more in
their pocket
thus they spend a little bit more money
thus businesses hire more people this
also has a little something to do with
because they all basically every uh red
state reopened sooner did not go as far
with lockdowns as the blue states etc
etc so this is good now the proof is in
the pudding all of the crap of the last
two years is showing that
there if you get out of the way of
people's lives they can make decisions
for themselves we got more from rnc
research
12 of the top 15 states for jobs
recovered from the pandemic are led by
republican governors okay once again
this is pretty good and it's freaking
obvious i am sitting in a room with
three people that left a blue state
and left jobs all i think you guys were
all paying taxes right everyone paid
taxes in this room not happily but okay
everyone so there's four of us in here
total and i have more employees than
this but i'm sitting here four people in
this room right now that were
functioning tax paying hard-working
decent citizens of california who fled
that dystopian [ __ ] to move to the
free state of florida and uh things are
pretty good here pretty good pretty good
pretty good pretty good pretty good okay
i got to put money in the jar because i
mentioned california
so it is obvious people are taking their
skills they're taking their families
they're taking their finances and
they're moving to places where people
work and of course what red states also
did was keep the schools open
so everybody that opposed having the
kids in school
they were wrong and we can never let
something like that happen in this
country again
that was ron desantis a couple days ago
that was at uh chelsea piers in new york
city and of course the crazy leftist
whack jobs were protesting him because
of the the don't say gay thing which uh
as you know is complete nonsense um so
okay so what do we got here if you get
out of people's way if you don't take
all their tax money if you don't lock
them down if you don't forcibly inject
them if you don't do all this [ __ ] then
people can kind of figure out things on
their own uh well you may remember from
my interview with desantis only two
three weeks ago now uh he got it right
and deserved some credit for it and the
fact is fauci was wrong about a lot of
this stuff
okay
we were the first big state to guarantee
every parent the ability to send their
kid to school in person way back in 2020
right
fauci opposed us having kids in school
he opposed what we were doing when we
had businesses open and protecting
people's jobs and were having these
events he opposed us every step of the
way and so that wasn't based on data
because the schooling was obvious that
you needed to have the kids in school it
was based more on ideology
okay so you guys get it the guy's doing
it right here in florida but now let's
shift to that change that i mentioned
earlier uh so maya flores won this seat
in texas it had been democrat controlled
for about 80 years she's the first
mexican congresswoman uh in texas in
this district this is this is a huge
change this is this is a serious note
like this is a bell weather moment for
the shift that is happening right now
and ron desantis chimed in on that don't
let anyone tell you that the only people
affected by illegal immigration are the
border towns that's just not true
although if you see what's happening now
down in the border towns you know you
just had the first republican elected in
southern south texas in a hundred years
in that congressional district
[Music]
and she ran she ran you know she's
mexican-american and she ran on
you know god country and strong borders
and really was focusing on on the border
so you have all those communities now
that have just been overrun
by the failure to maintain the border
and now they're really fighting back in
terms of they're doing stuff to try to
mitigate it there but politically now
they're saying they've had enough of
this and no one would have said if we
were here five years ago and you said
that that she could have won everyone
would have said there's no way you could
ever do it well now you're seeing it
so you get it
they're gonna keep trying to scare the
hell out of you it doesn't mean that
things are great right everyone's
looking at their bank accounts
everyone's looking at their 401ks
everyone's looking at the stock market
and all the gas prices and all that i
can't just sit here and tell you
everything is freaking fantastic because
it is not but the markers for how we
will win the markers for how we will
turn this thing around they're all there
they're all there whether it is rand
paul calling out the [ __ ] of fouchy
and more and more people realizing that
that is what it is where more and more
people go no no no no you're not going
to inject my five-year-old whether it is
maya flores winning this seat in texas
right
all of these things are the markers and
if we just keep not just glossing over
them but really sitting with them and
going man there are things that are
happening here enough people watching
biden fall off the bike and going uh you
know maybe
maybe president kamala harris maybe
that's a little scarier than i thought
it was
well then
we can all continue this mass awakening
not awokening that i think is happening
all over the country uh you're gonna
want to stick around for the cold
clothes we got for you today do we have
a couple comments from the locals
community oh it's me monday over at
locals i i put this one up myself i
thought this was pretty appropriate it's
a take off of a famous meme that goes
around it's biden just doing it to
himself and on the floor poor joe poor
joe very sad all right we got a couple
comments from the locals community and i
said to my guys right before we started
for those of you that are watching on
rumble right now obviously uh you know
youtube is what it is uh rumble does
rumble rants we're gonna read some
comments off rumble starting tomorrow as
well in addition to the locals uh
comments uh tall says do these people
really believe these apologies work all
it does is empower the mob to come after
them even harder like blood in the water
to a school of sharks yes you are
absolutely right the apology never works
what it shows people is that you will
live on your knees forever and no one
even believes it right that's why you
know the
the rain wilson apology was like i
talked to my friends and i realized my
trans friends and i realized chess
feeding breastfeeding it's like blah
it's just it's just verbal diarrhea it's
just meaningless drivel nothing and
you're apologizing to people who
would never grant you
any goodness in life they just want you
to apologize forever and never say what
you really think that's what this is
really about but the the james patterson
won his worst because james patterson
clearly said what he thought what to be
true that of course there is this is
what all woke-ism leads to this is what
equity leads to as i said earlier if
you're going to promote one group based
on the color of skin or on an immutable
characteristic you have to be prejudiced
against another group so at a publishing
company the idea is we are here to
promote black writers well then that
means it doesn't mean that there's more
jobs to be had more books to be printed
you're gonna have to discriminate so
he's told the truth i will tell you a
very specific example of exactly what
he's talking about in our in our old
house in l.a in my studio there the guy
who had done the lighting for me and he
had done it for several of my studios
the old one in my garage and a bunch
more and he'd i'd worked with him for
years on a bunch of different things he
was an emmy award-winning lighting guy
in hollywood he happens to be about 65
and white and he's straight as well
at least he's married to a chick he's
straight um he was told uh about halfway
through kovid that he should retire that
he should just go ahead and retire he
was told that by studio executives
because they were like you know
basically they basically said your time
is over meaning you're 65 you're white
you're straight like we got to give
these lighting jobs to to younger black
trans whatever people it is true we all
know it's true it is obvious and it's
true and of course what it will also do
is it will degrade the work over time if
you just hire people based on the color
of their skin and not whether they're
the best lighting people or the best
engineers or the best plumbers or
whatever it might be the best pilots or
doctors you're going to have worse
products over time and that's why in
some way to me it's like let them keep
building
you know shitty products because they
will just destroy themselves and much
like i do with this company and much
like hopefully you do with whatever
company you work for or work in or own
it's like hire people based on skill
hire people because they're good people
and work hard you don't care if they're
black or white or trans or gay or
anything else if that if they happen to
be any of those things then zippity
dippity and move on with life and we
will build better products and a better
a better society it's really that simple
tallway says the atlantic needs to be
thrown into its namesake oh that's funny
yeah i mean it's just pure trash all of
these places that they think we have no
memory and that's why sometimes i show a
lot of old clips of things because i
think one of the key things is as we're
slammed with information and as we
scroll on our phones endlessly you know
with this bottomless scroll this never
ending thing that never stops it's
almost all designed to make us crazy and
never remember anything right so the
atlantic it's like when they write oh
biden fell off a bike it's so wonderful
we can it's a reminder that we should
all get up when we fall off our bike
it's like you know they wouldn't have
done that on trump and as i said we
could have showed you 20 headlines of
when they went after trump for
two-handed water drinks and whatever
else it might be and it's like that's
why i show you all clips because we
can't forget what they've done and
that's what they want you to forget
through endless scroll and endless
outrage and endless fear right the fear
of msnbc they're coming for your rights
black people
paradise says i have to admit i chuckled
at the video clip of joey boy falling
over but then i was reminded that we are
one broken hip away from president
kamala to which i abruptly stopped and
said walk it off man yeah that was it
that was it when i saw the clip that the
first thing that lit up in my head it's
like i don't like biden obviously i
think he is a liar i think he is
mentally compromised i think his
administration is horrible i think he
has surrounded himself with inept
buffoons i think obama's running the
show i think they've ushered in wokeness
and socialism and all of the stuff
but man he would still be better than
kamala and that tells you this really
whacked out place that we are going to
be in for another two and a half years
can you believe we have two and a half
more years of it that's what david said
to me over the weekend when we when i
showed him the video and he's like oh my
god kamala could be president
and then he's like how much longer do we
have we're only a year and a half into
this tragedy this travesty this
embarrassment
if you pray now is the time uh guys
reminder uh you can watch my stand-up
special you can buy it one time for 9.99
don't say dave it's up at locals go to
reubenreport.locals.com i promise you
will laugh for 40 minutes the people are
digging it it's fun and funny and silly
and uh i know you'll enjoy it that's all
i've got to say about that
finally oh my full interview with
senator mike lee from utah is up right
now across platforms and uh speaking of
kamala harris here's today's cold
clothes see you tomorrow
and now
veep thoughts
by kamala harris
we will work together and continue to
work together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges
and to work together as we continue to
work
operating from the new norms rules and
agreements
that we will convene
to work together on and i know we will
work on this together
[Music]
this has been
veep thoughts
by kamala harris